in this course you will learn how to
create a custom website without any code
using elementor and wordpress i'm beau
with freecodecamp.org
i've created a few popular wordpress
courses and this one is specifically
focused on elementor elementor is a free
wordpress website builder and this
course is all you need to learn how to
build a bunch of different types of
websites and you don't need any prior
experience to follow along you will
learn a drag and drop system that allows
for easy and limitless customization so
you can build the perfect website for
your needs and the website will look
great on both desktop and mobile so
let's get started the first step is to
get a domain name and hosting we'll be
getting that at hostinger.com but you
can still follow along if you use a
different hosting provider hostinger
provided a grant that made this course
possible but i had already used
hostinger personally in the past and had
a good experience hostinger is optimized
for wordpress sites and has a 99.9
uptime guarantee
they also give you a free domain and
free ssl so we can just go here get
click get started
and then you can decide whether you're
going to create a brand new website or
transfer an existing website well we're
creating a brand new website
and
you can you don't have to go through all
this but we are doing a wordpress here
and i'm just going to
go through here and it'll tell you what
kind of package we want to do so
we can just
skip this for now because this is
actually an upgrade but we don't want to
upgrade so i'll just go to skip here
and then it's going to recommend the
premium shared hosting plan so
you can actually go and just select your
plan manually but this will help you
figure out the exact plan you want you
can see right here you can actually host
a hundred different websites on this
plan and you get a good amount of
storage and you get unlimited bandwidth
so that's pretty good you includes a
free domain
and then ssl will make it so you have a
secure website so this is a good option
so i'm just going to select that
and then it's going to show where you
can actually upgrade if you want or you
you can choose a different amount of
months
and you can see depending on how many
months you buy a time is is how much
it's going to renew for so you can see
this one
renews at 699 799 899 or 11.99 a month
so just pick whatever one you think is
gonna work best for you if you're just
testing it out you could just do a the
one month plan or if you know you're
going to have a website long term you
can do one of these other plans and then
um after you get all this set up you can
go through just to create the account
and you can select your payment and then
you can submit it so i'm not actually
going to type in everything but it's
pretty straightforward if you're going
to create your own account for the first
time
so after you get logged in and possibly
as part of creating your account you're
going to want to get your domain so if
you're done creating your account and
you haven't gotten a domain through that
process yet we can just click on claim
domain right in the main menu
now here is you you're going to have to
have a domain name that's never been
used before
it could take you a few tries to find
one that's not already taken but i'm
going to go with
b-e-a-u with the dashes that's my name
bo but my name doesn't have dashes but
o.net let's check availability
and i already tested this so i knew it
knew it would work
and i will claim domain
okay
now we have to set up this domain
registration details
and we'll just finish filling this out
okay the domain is registered
okay now add the website to the hosting
plan
and i already had this hosting plan
registered for this other website so
select that one
website connected successfully
now i'll show you how to set up an email
account on your domain through hostinger
so i'm on the hostinger home tab
after i'm logged in and i'm going to
just click emails
and now i'm going to the so i already
set up this one before but now i'm going
to set the email on the domain we just
created so i'm just going to click there
and then create email account
and then i'm just going to
type in it automatically filled in
something but i can type in anything i
want so i'm going to put bow and then
i'm just going to type in a password
here
and then create
okay so now people can email me at bo b
dash e a dash u.net
and then i can access the email by still
being on this email tab here and going
to webmail
and then i'll just sign in here
and there are no messages but i can
always compose a new message here and
then i'll receive messages if someone
sends me a message
and now let's go over how to set up ssl
for the website so i'm going to go to
the ssl tab on this hosting or dashboard
and ssl is important it makes sure all
data coming and going from your website
is secure and nobody's going to be able
to
there there won't be any hackers or
anybody that can see what's going on
with the website if someone submits
information it'll be secure nobody will
be able to see what that information is
so i'm just going to click the install
ssl button and then i'm going to select
the website and just click install ssl
and the great thing is that it's it's
free it's completely included
within hosting or within the plan and
now i should have ssl but i'm going to
actually do this drop down menu to go to
the bow.net to see the one that we just
added
and you can see it's installing it says
it may take up to an hour but then after
that
we can go to the website instead of
going to http colon slash bo.net it will
be http s
colon slash bo.net because it has the
ssl it's the the s stands for secure
i'll go back to the dashboard
now i want to get wordpress installed on
the website many different website
hosting services allow you to easily
install wordpress on the website so the
exact method could be different if
you're not using hostinger but it should
be relatively similar so i'm just going
to scroll down on this page here and i'm
going to click
wordpress
and then i'm going to install wordpress
and i'll fill this out to finish setting
up so let's call it
my website for now and anything here can
be changed later
and then i'll put in the password
[Music]
and then i'll just use these default
settings here and click install
we're on the hostinger dashboard
but we want to go to the wordpress
dashboard so we can start creating our
wordpress website so i'll just click on
edit website
if you're using something besides beside
wordpress there'll be something similar
to get into the wordpress dashboard
another way you can always access your
wordpress dashboard if you look in the
url bar here we have the url name and
then it's slash wp-admin
you can always go to slash wp-admin to
get to your wordpress dashboard
okay i've zoomed in a little bit on this
and we're just going to look at some of
the things on the menu over here these
are all things that are important when
creating a wordpress page we have our
posts when we're going to create a new
post but you're likely going to be
creating a new page like the about us
page contact page and stuff like that
and we'll be going over that more later
and you can also change your appearance
and there's just a bunch of other
sections here many of which will be
going over in more detail later in this
tutorial but first of all let's go over
to users and you just want to make sure
that you have a
a password we just want to make sure
that the password is the password we
chose now depending on how you installed
wordpress you may not have created a
password and depending on what hosting
provider you use and you just might want
to make maybe verify that you're not
going to have a default password so i'm
just going to type in a password here
and then
i'm going to do update profile
okay now we're going to go to the
plugins tab
before we deal with the plugins let's
just get rid of some of these tabs i'm
going to
click x here we don't need this i guess
they're not tabs they're just
information boxes
and to get rid of this one we're going
to go through and actually delete some
of the extra plugins here we don't a lot
of these plugins we don't actually need
so i've selected all the extra plugins
and i don't need this one either
and i'm going to go
to oh first i'll do deactivate
and then i'll just select them again and
i'm going to go to delete
and don't worry if you accidentally
delete a plug-in that you actually need
because it's really easy to
reinstall them so i'm going to go to
delete
okay and now we've deleted all the
plugins we don't need and you can see we
no longer have the extra information box
up here those associated with a
particular pro plugin so now i'm going
to go to add new
this is an elementor tutorial so we
could just install directly like this by
searching for
elementor
and then we could click install now but
we're actually going to
install it a little differently we're
going to install something else that
will in turn install elementor it will
install some themes it will install some
templates and so we'll get everything in
one by installing one thing so instead
i'm going to search for starter starter
templates
[Music]
okay this is going to install elementor
plus a few other things that are going
to be helpful so i'm just going to click
install now
and activate
so let me go here down here and click
see library
and we don't need to watch this video
here i'm going to click on build your
website now
and then you can click which plate you
can choose what page builder you're
going to use so in this tutorial we're
learning about elementor so i'll click
elementor
and then it's going to give you a list
of templates you can use
so you can see some of these are premium
so you get to pay extra for but there is
a bunch of really good free templates
and i highly recommend starting your
website by using a template and then you
can customize the template to meet your
specific needs
so go through and look at these
templates and try to see what template
looks closest to the website that you
want to make
and then you can modify that template to
meet your specific needs
so i'm going to choose this one but keep
in mind everything is super customizable
so no matter what one you choose you're
going to be able to add sections remove
sections
change colors change pictures to make it
so it meets your needs so i'm going to
click this one here
and it's already
showing how we can customize things by
adding a logo and different things like
that but we're going to do all of that
later so i'm going to do skip and
continue
and it's going to
show you can actually
choose different colors and fonts but
again we're just going to do all this
later because we just want to get the
template installed on our wordpress
instance and then we'll do all the
customization later so it says one last
step
and then we can choose some of these
advanced options so we are going to
install this theme to go along with it
the astra theme and the customizer
settings we're just going to keep all
these checked except i don't want to
share any data and then import content
this is this will import dummy pages
posts images and menus so we could
uncheck it if you want to do everything
from scratch but i like starting with
things and it's easier to change things
once you once you start with something
so i'm going to click submit and build
the res the website and you notice i
didn't even have to put in any
information about my name or my email
address or anything like that
okay the website is ready i'll go to
view your website
and this is the website
so it basically just installed
everything all the the sample images and
stuff like that and you can see there's
different sections the home about
services
and the great thing about this is we can
edit everything this doesn't have to be
a services page we can make this into
anything it can be a product page it can
be a more information page
maybe it could show a list of different
people that worked at our company so
we're going to be able to update all
this stuff to meet our specific needs
and you can see right now these are all
dummy links if i click start a project
it doesn't do anything
and we have a contact page here
so let's see how we can start updating
this website using elementor to be the
exact website we need for our project
and so we can't edit anything right now
this is just the view mode but to edit
it we can go to edit with elementor
just click edit with elementor
and it's going to load that
and now we have the site right here but
then we also have the elementor editing
menu over here and this is what we're
going to use to add sections modify
sections
and just
make the website be exactly what we want
to be using elementor
so first of all we have the navigator
here which will help us select different
sections on our website so here's the
first section right here and then here
it's going to go to the second section
and you can see whenever you select a
section it's going to put a blue outline
around it so you can see this blue here
here this blue line around the outline
and then you can see you can select the
section with these buttons here
this is how you would add a new section
and i can just delete that with this x
here
or you can delete a section or if i
click here
this is how i would move the section
around
so this we can select down here the
bottom section but we don't even need
the navigator i'm going to close the
navigator because you can select a
selection just by clicking on it so when
i move my mouse over a section you can
see the blue outline goes around that
section
and i already showed you that if you
click the plus button you can add a new
section and then we can bring over
widgets so i'm actually going to go over
here
and get to the elements tab here and
these are all widgets i can bring in so
i can bring in an image i'll drag this
image in here
and then it's going to this is like the
default thing here but i can actually
choose an image and there's already
images here that came with the website
i'll be showing you how to add more
later but like for example i could add a
picture of this man and then it will
be right here now obviously that's not
really what we want so i'll x this here
but let me show you one thing another
thing is that there are often different
columns
so when we first create a section there
is just one big
column but if i click the plus button i
can choose the structure is it just me
one big area are there going to be two
columns three columns four columns and
you can see what if i want a small
section here and a big section over here
you can change the size by dragging this
around here and then you can add
different things to different sections
so if i click the plus button that's
going to bring up these different
widgets
and like i already showed you had an
image but maybe we want to add a heading
here
and then after the heading you may want
to add something after the heading so if
i
go back to these widgets i may want to
add a text so we have the heading and we
have the text here and over here we may
want to add a video and when you edit
video you can link to a specific youtube
video or you can
choose a few different sources including
self-hosted so there's just quite a few
different things you can do by adding
different sections and different widgets
and soon i'll be going into more detail
about more things you can do with these
sections in these widgets and show you
how and then i'll show you how to modify
the current sections on the website so
i'm going to delete this extra section
now and i wanted to show you one other
cool thing about starting with a
template like this
it's already set up to be responsive so
if i click this here there's a button on
here says responsive mode and then i can
choose am i do i want to look at it like
it's a desktop a tablet or a mobile
device i'm going to click mobile device
so you can see as i scroll down
everything gets drunk into a
uh one column that's going to look
better on a mobile device i can go back
to the desktop site
and if i'm done testing out these
different sizes i can just hit x here
now we're going to actually start
customizing this page to meet our needs
first of all we can always preview
changes so we haven't made any changes
but you can always go back to the main
page by going preview changes i'm going
to go back to the home and i'm going to
just click edit with elementor again
and so now we're at the at the home page
again
and you can customize
the website to be any type of page it
can be a blog it can be a business page
it can be an online store
there's tons of possibilities an
elementor can basically make any type of
page you want to make it
and just for fun we're going to
customize this page so it's a store that
sells unicycles like i said you can make
yours anything you like so let's look at
this text here
so
for one you can easily change any text
you see on the screen so i can say
unicycles we all love unicycles there we
go and then let's say we don't we want a
different font if you want a different
font there's a few ways to go about it
you can select the text you can go to
style and then i can go to typography
and i can go to here and i can change to
a different font here so i could change
change it to
verdana
or times new roman
or i can basically i can choose any font
here there's even these google fonts
here you can actually load any fonts
from google fonts
but let's say we know that we want all
our fonts to be the same you may not so
this is the way where you would do it
individually you could select every
single text box and change that font but
there's also a way to change all of the
fonts at once so i'm going to go back to
default here and now i'm going to go to
content or i'm going to click this
hamburger menu and go to site settings
so then i'm going to go to typography
and now we're going to change the
typography for the entire site
and you can see here that there's
different sections
this is the body typography uh links h1
h2 so
h1 would be a heading so like this is
probably either an h1 or h2
h1 is the biggest heading then h2 is the
smaller heading so this is probably
either an h2 or h3 so we can go through
and change
the typography and it will affect
everything on the site so like body
would be
text of a paragraph like this so i'm
going to go into
the typography for the body
and i'm going to change this to
georgia so we can see it change this
font here you can see that change the
font on the button here and it will just
change it all over our site here and
then for the headings i'm going to do a
little different i'm going to go into
the typography here
and i'm going to use
trebuchet
and so you can see the font changed and
you can see we can also change the the
weight transform style decoration line
height some of this stuff i think is
better to do
for each individual
heading like
the the height the letter spacing you're
probably not going to want to change the
letter spacing for your entire site
there could be some specific headings
where you want to do that so we're going
to leave that all as the default here
and then i'm just going to go through
and change all the headings because
right now if we see we can see this does
not look like the same font as
this and then this is a different font
so i'm going to go through and just
change all these headings to use that
same font
and after you make any changes you have
to make sure to click the update button
so
now it says your changes have been
updated so this is going to make sure to
save all the changes we just made
so now let's go ahead and update this
background image
this section right here is often called
a hero section it's like the first big
section you see on a website and we want
this background image to relate to
unicycles in some way so what i'm going
to do is click these six little dots at
the this top this blue section edit
section
and then i am going to go to style and
then we have the image here i'm gonna
click choose image and there's a few
different ways to do this so so if we go
to update files i can select files on my
computer we can also go to the media
library and it's it
the website started with all these
images basically in here by default but
we're going to be updating most of them
but another thing you can do is go to
free images so here this says powered by
pixabay so that's a website that you can
get free royalty free images and so i'm
just going to search
unicycle and then see what comes up here
so let's see which picture would be a
good background picture
so i like this one it's going to have
multiple unicycles and this looks like a
pretty good size so i'm going to just
click insert media
and then let me just click choose images
again
let's see
insert media
okay i must have clicked the wrong thing
or something okay here it goes and now
we can see we have this unicycle picture
in the background
and then one thing i noticed is that now
that we have this picture here the text
is a little harder to read
so i can go to where it says background
overlay
and i can change this opacity
so see i can make this a little darker
if i make this darker then you can see
that the white text shows up a little
better so i like that better and the
overlay was already on there it started
out at 0.2 and i've increased it to 0.61
let's just do it at 0.6
and yeah i like this
so you can you can try different things
you can change what the color is the
base color here is black but we can make
the base color something else it's just
up to you on what what you want this to
look like
there's actually a lot of other changes
you can make to make this look exactly
how you want
for example you may want to actually
make this a gradient so we have the
overlay it's just black but you could
maybe go from black and maybe you want
to be red at the bottom or maybe a blue
so it's going to kind of
go from black to blue
and then you can
change the location of where it where
the second color starts so now the blue
starts toward the bottom
and then you can also change if it's
going to be like a circle where it's
black in the middle and then blue on the
right but we are going to just go back
to the classic just the single color
black and if i go back up to the
background here we can also change the
position so right now it's center center
but i could make it um like top right so
it's it's going to kind of move the
image around now we're not seeing too
much movement with this image it
basically just depends on what size of
image you're starting with like what the
the aspect ratio of the image you're
starting with
and then we're not going to do this but
one one thing you can do is instead of
having an image here you could put a
video here so i could put a link to a
video they'll just play in the
background and we can still have the
color overlay to make it so the text
pops up
pops up a lot and then you can also
use a slideshow so you can make it
switch between different images again
let's just go back to classic we're just
going to use this image we already found
here so now let's make some additional
changes here so
we are i kind of like how it says we all
love unicycles but we don't need this
text here so i'm going to click here
okay i'm just going to adjust this so it
wasn't showing this will edit thing but
now it is so i'm going to click here and
then click this edit
and this is allowing us to edit over
here but if we don't want to actually
edit the text or anything i can just
right click on it and go to delete so
now we just completely deleted
that
text
and look where it says we all love
unicycles
we can make some adjustments in here
like for instance this word unicycles is
pretty big but
you know i want to make even bigger so
i'm going to go to style
and then i am going to go to typography
and then i can change the size here so
it's even bigger here and then there's a
bunch of other things i can do like for
instance i could make it so it's bold
and then i can change the letter spacing
it's at negative three but let's say i
want to kind of fill out more so i'm
gonna just go to uh
five
so we all love unicycles and it's it's
spreading out the letters a little more
and we can also even change the color if
we wanted now i kind of like the white
so i'm going to go back to the white but
one thing that i would like to do is add
a text shadow now you're not going to
see it too much because it's dark in the
background
but
i just increase this here
oh it changed the color
so it's a little darker
and now you can kind of see the the
shadow
there we go and decrease the blur
okay now like i said it's going to show
up more depending on what what
background image you have but that's
just one of the options you can do when
you're changing the text
now if you remember we deleted the text
that was after this word but what if you
decide that's a mistake you actually do
want text after that word well i can go
up here
and
here we go now i can drag in this
intersection and i can just put where oh
actually that's the wrong one the text
editor and i can put it right under the
word so now we have this this here now
i'm going to have to
do some style edits to make it look like
what we wanted so i'm going to click
this little edit button here
and i'll go to style
and then i can change the text color i'm
going to go to white
i can go the typography so i can make
the the weight a little more i'm going
to make this bold
and
i'm going to
just
so put down here so let me just delete
this here and you can see this is just
sample text we're not going to bother
updating a lot of the sample text
obviously in a real world situation
you'll you'll update it to put the text
that goes along with what you're trying
to do here
i'm going to center this
i want this you the word unicycles to be
a little closer to this so what we're
going to do is actually click on the
word unicycles i'm going to go to
advanced and we're going to make changes
to the margin and the padding so the
padding is going to be the space kind of
within the element and the margin is
going to be the space outside the
element so you can see the negative 50
that's why this this top blue line
is um kind of coming through that part
of the i and l if we change this to
30
you can see that it increases that
margin up there i'm going to keep this
at 50
and
so you can actually you can change
everything
all at once if you link them together so
i can
just add padding all at once
wait it wasn't linked now it's linked
together so now it's adding the padding
all at once
but we just want to
actually
change how close unicycles is to down
here so on bottom i'm going to unlink it
and i'm going to just
actually the padding is not going to
help the the margin is going to help
again sometimes you just have to play
around with it to see what's going to
look best so i'm going to
decrease that
so now that this text here is closer to
the word unicycle
so now i'm going to show you let's say
you actually did have a longer phrase
here i'm just going to copy this and
then put it in here and so let's say you
had a phrase that went about this long
now why is that white there
let's try that again
there we go so let's say you had a
phrase that went this long but you want
the text to not go so far out to the
edge but let's see how we can change the
width so this text is about as long as
the word unicycles well we're going to
click on this this dots here to change
the settings for this whole section let
me go to advanced
and
or actually it's layout we go to layout
and then we'll go down to width so width
here we have it as box but i'm going to
actually do a custom width here
and so it's going to this is like the
full width but if i go down you can see
it's changing the width here
i don't want it so far down that the
word unicycle starts going to the next
line
but
that looks pretty good so now this text
isn't going to go all the way off to the
side
so now let's make a change to this
button it doesn't really get started
that doesn't make sense
when it relates to this unicycle store
so i'm going to click this button here
and i'm going to change the text
so to change the text i just go to this
thing that says text here instead of get
started we're going to say c
unicycles and this will take it to it
will take people to a page showing all
the different unicycles that are
available at the store
and we can
change the style just like we would do
any of these other things so you can add
an icon here
or you can change the alignment but and
you can also just change the style so i
am going to change this i don't instead
of using that specific font i don't like
that font for a button so instead of
using the the default
text i'm going to go down here
and i'm going to use
a google font or x i don't like that one
let's try one more
there we go and then i'm going to change
the size here
i'm going to change the weight i'm going
to change it to 800
and then i'm going to change the the
background color so this yellow i'm not
going to use yellow i'm going to
go to this background type
and right now
i can select any color here
i kind of like this orange color now if
we want to make sure to use the same
color elsewhere in our website i can
click this plus button to create a new
global color
and
i will call this unit orange
and create so now we can easily select
that same color for other sections of
the website now that we have this color
i'm going to go back to this
text color and then i'm going to cr make
it white
okay that looks good
and
you may have noticed if i go back to the
um the content tab we can change where
the the link's going to go so i can type
in the a page on us a page on our
website like maybe it'll be about.html
and uh right now we'll later we'll have
to verify that we have the page called
about.html
so now let's see how to modify more
sections so we i don't think we're going
to need every
section in on this page like this quote
here i don't think we'll need this so
i'm going to just x that out and close
that and this we're going to modify it
so instead of our services we'll do our
unicycles
and then i'm going to update these
pictures so i'm just going to click on
the picture
and then i'll click choose image
and
previously when you weren't watching i
uploaded some pictures of different
unicycles i just went to upload files
select files and select them selected
them on my computer so we're going to
insert some of these unicycles
so just go here
choose image
and then choose another image
and then you can obviously go through
and
change the text here
so
i'll put
a
fat tire
long rides
tall
unicycle
and then we can also go through and make
changes to this so i'm gonna go to this
fat tire section i'm going to click this
edit
button here whoops
i can always just do command or ctrl z
to undo
so i'm i have this i have the
title and description so here's the
title here's the description
and i'm going to change the style i'm
going to scroll down to content so in
the content
i can
change so we have the title here and
then the description here
so i can just change the title i'm going
to change the color of the title and i'm
going to
actually go to the the global i'm going
to click here where we can choose the
color that we create if i scroll down
uni orange
and then the typography i'm going to
change a little bit i'm going to change
the weight to 900
and then style i'll make this italic
and then i'll change the alignment to
center so this whole thing is going to
be centered now what i can do is right
click and i'm going to copy and now i
can paste the style
see i can paste the style here so now we
have everything centered it has the
different
color for the title and that's looking
pretty good
so
we have in about us in a question so we
don't need this questions page here
but let's say we want to add a new
section so we already saw how you could
click here and and
add these different columns and then
bring in over these other widgets but
there's another way if i click this s
here
so this should look familiar we were
able to choose different templates and
we chose this one but there's this other
tab here blocks
so if i look through here i can look at
something that looks similar to what i
want to
put in
and i kind of like this the frequently
asked questions
so you may not want to add a frequently
asked questions but if you if it looks
similar to what you want to add that's a
good thing to add you can see there's
actually some different different ways
it could look so i'm going to choose
this one here and import block
okay and then we can go through here and
so this is kind of cool how you can
minus and plus it to make the answer go
go up and down it's called an accordion
and you can see according items so
if i click in here i can actually change
the text of the title and the
description so i can say
what kind of
unicycles
do you have
and i can
update this we have all types
and then
on the page people can kind of go minus
or plus
and then for now i'm going to update
this
now i'm going to after it finishes
update dating
i'm going to click this little side
arrow so this is going to close this
close the side menu and then we can see
more of what it's going to look like so
with that closed this is more like what
it's going to look like i still have the
responsive screen up here so i can close
that here
but you can see it has all these changes
and so it's starting to look more
customized
now i'm going to talk a little bit more
about what you can do when you're adding
custom sections now i already showed you
how to add a section by clicking the
plus arrow and by clicking this now i'm
going to show you a few extra features
that you can do like i'm
so i'm just going to add a section just
like this and it's going to have these
two sections so i'm going to just add
something to the section so for instance
i'll add a button to this one
and then to this one we will add
a heading so when you're trying to get
everything to look exactly like you want
one thing that you may want to do is to
add a background image so if i click
this and then if i go to style
actually advanced go to advanced and
then i can go down to background here
and i am going to add
an image
so just click this
and then we'll just click we'll just
choose one of these images that were
that were already uploaded
and then when we see the image it just
looks like a solid color that's because
we're just seeing the top of the image
so we're going to want to position it so
i can use this positioning i can even go
to a custom position and i can change
this
and let me change the y position so we
can see so now we can see actually some
some trees in there and then we also
to make this bigger to make where the
image is we can add some padding so let
me
click here again and then we're going to
go up to layout
and in the in the
we're going to unlink here and then i'm
going to add some more padding on top
here
and then i'm going to add some more
padding on bottom i'm actually going to
use 75
up top and 75 at bottom
and then i'm going to add some padding
on the left let's do 15.
so you can mess with the padding to kind
of choose how big a section is going to
be and where things are going to be like
let's say we want this button to be at
the bottom well we can just change this
padding to 25 and then this padding to
125
and then it's the same size here but the
button is now down here
and then let's go over here
if i go into this section with this
heading here if i want to
edit this section i can click this
button here
and then i'm also going to change the
background
type this time we'll do a gradient so
i'll go from blue or i guess yeah blue
to red there you're probably never going
to want to do a gradient like that
but i'm just kind of showing you some
examples of what you can do
if i go to layout here i can change the
vertical and horizontal alignment so the
vertical alignment is default but i'm
going to put it at bottom so now what
you can see is bring the text to the
very bottom it's just so here we kind of
use the padding to change where the
button was but you can also use the
vertical alignment and sometimes that
can even be a better way of doing it
now whether you want to do it with the
padding or you want to do the vertical
alignment that can depend on
what you're going for so it's going to
look very different in when we go to the
the mobile responsive mode so if i click
responsive mode up here and go to mobile
i'm going to scroll down and we can see
here because of the padding it's going
to always be kind of the same height
here
but this section is not going to be the
same height because remember before it
was side by side what we had this box on
the left and this box on the right and
so this box would just kind of fill the
space of this if we wanted this box to
be the same height we would just add
additional padding or margin on the top
okay i'll go out of this
and i'm actually just going to delete
this whole section i just wanted to
teach you more about
the background images the padding and
margin and different things you can do
in that regard so i'm going to just x
out of this
now we'll talk a little bit more about
adding videos i briefly mentioned it
before but let's go through and this
image we're going to convert into a
video so really what i'm going to do
first is just delete the image
so i'm going to bring in this video here
and i already talked about the different
ways you can have a source for the video
but
youtube is generally the easiest i'm
just going to paste in a video i found
this unicycling video that we're going
to use but one thing it starts with
these titles here that i don't want to
have so i'm going to
make the start time be seven seconds so
i'll just put in seven seconds for the
start time
and then it will start at that exact
time
and
there's all these different things for
the options you can do autoplay i'm
going to make it so it mutes i'm going
to make it yeah i'll make it so it loops
and then i am gonna make it so it auto
plays now you're generally
probably don't want your video to auto
play but if you wanna if you're putting
as a background video there may be a
time where you would want it to auto
play but generally people don't like it
when videos are audio playing so you
know we'll just turn it off for now
so now when people get to this page um
we'll put that down they can
start the video and it automatically
starts after the titles and then they
can watch all these unicycle tricks
so let's just update this
so it kind of relates to the video
[Music]
we offer courses
to improve
your eunice unicycle
skills
and then find out more
and you can we can always link to where
the the where the person can find out
more right here
and this about us i don't think we even
need that so i'm going to delete that
now i notice that this section this
these sections all kind of blend
together so let's add a new background
to this and i'll show you some different
things you can do when you're adding
backgrounds so click these dots and i'm
going to go to
styles
and
background so this time i'm going to do
a gradient
the first color i'm actually going to
choose our uni orange
and then the second color i'm going to
go for
white
and then with this angle we can actually
change the angle of where how the
gradients going and see and right now
it's kind of a gradient but there's
we can actually change the amount of
gradient by by messing with the location
so so the location will choose where the
gradient starts you can kind of see how
it's as i move it where the orange kind
of goes back and forth but i can also
move this white back and forth
so the closer we get this together
you know the less of a gradient and so
we can make just a solid line like that
i can change the angle like that
and that i can
make it go this way
and now we're going to do
5757
so
now we still want to make this separate
so i'm actually going to change this
white
to a
slight light blue now this probably
isn't the best design choice but i'm
just kind of just showing you what's
possible
and i want to show you another cool
thing i'm going to
go out of background and go into
background overlay
so i'm going to go to choose image and
i'm going to upload a file
and then i'm going to
insert the image
and this is not exactly what we want you
can see it's like repeating this
unicycle i i got a picture with a
transparent background so i'm going to
so i'm going to change the size
so the size is it's not going to go
bigger than the section and repeat we're
going to do no repeat
and then i'm going to change the
position
i'm going to
position it in the on the right side so
you can see it's kind of behind this
section here
and then just adjust the video size here
and now i'm going for attachment i'm
going to go fixed so if it's fixed
then when we scroll you can see
the unicycle kind of behind the image
that actually changed the size so i'm
going to change the size
and i'm going to do
custom
let's see what size we want
okay that looks pretty good
and now you can see when you scroll down
you can see this unicycle in the
background over on the side
over on the side
so that looks pretty cool
i'm just going to do one quick thing i'm
going to custom i'm going to put this
into a custom position
so
it's not quite all the way to the edge
so it's like right in the middle of this
video
and now let's try it
okay
um
now let's just move it down a little bit
okay so now when you scroll down you can
see the that unicycle moving in the
background well we probably put in
enough time on this so let's just update
this and we're just going to
check what our page looks like so far
now we see when i do this and the
unicycle kind of changes position we can
actually fix that by
the way
changing the x position so it's a
percentage so let's do
60 percent for the x percent or maybe
80
so now with the x position being a
percentage like that
if we go
if we change the size of how wide the
page is it's still going to be the same
percentage into the page
so another thing you may want to add in
this section that we haven't covered yet
is social icons so i'm just going to add
one more section and show how you can
add some social icons to share your
twitter instagram youtube or any other
site like that so i'm going to create a
section here with two columns
and in this column i'm just going to
search for a widget i'm going to type in
social i can bring that right into here
now it defaults for facebook twitter and
youtube but i can also add an item so
right now it defaults to wordpress but i
can just go into the icon library here
and i can choose any of the other ones
it's deep it's showing all these
different
links i could add there
so i'm going to find instagram
so if i just scroll up here you can see
there are quite a few things we can
choose from so do instagram here and
insert so now it's instagram it's the
instagram logo here and then you can add
a link so uh for instance for youtube
i'm just going to add a youtube link
and we can use the official color of
youtube which is red or we can do a
custom color if we want to do a
different color so well we have all you
can add but just click here you can add
a link for each social item
and then you can even change the shape
like right now it's rounded but we can
change them to circles or square
how many columns you want the alignment
centered and then here i'm going to add
a heading
and i'm going to
put
follow us on social media
so we have the social media and then
here and then if i click here i can
change the background so this section
maybe i want a background overlay and
i'm going to change the color
to our uni orange color and then i'll
update that
so this is all we're going to do for our
home page but let's just make sure
everything's going to look good on a
mobile device so i'm going to go to the
responsive mode and go to mobile and so
now we're just going to start the top
and we're just going to scroll down
okay if we go down we can see this
unicycle thing this unicycle in the
background it's in the corner but
let's make it so just in mobile mode
it's going to appear in a different spot
so
i'm going to
click
here to be editing this section and
remember that was in background overlay
and now we have it's showing that it's
in mobile mode right here so any changes
i make here it's only going to impact
the mobile section
so i'm going to
make
this kind of right in the middle
and i am on the percentage here
so that's good so 50
and then i am going to make this
fixed and says attachment fix works only
on desktop
so i think that's
as good as we're gonna get on this let's
just move this up a little bit
and
i'm gonna change the opacity a little
more in mobile so you can see a little
better
okay if we keep scrolling down here we
can see
this looks pretty good but how about
this let's make this heading let's make
it center only on mobile so i am
clicking the edit button here and we can
see it's showing it's only on mobile i'm
going to click center
so
in this way we can go and make changes
that only impact
mobile so like for instance we made the
center on mobile but if i go back to
desktop it's going to be left aligned
so you can make sure
things look good on mobile and specify
specific settings that only apply to
mobile or only apply to desktop
another common thing that you're going
to want to change on mobile is just the
the text size like the this actually
looks pretty good but sometimes you're
going to say oh just on mobile we want
this to be a smaller text size so it's
pretty straightforward if you're going
to do that you just go to typography and
we can see it's in mobile mode and then
i'm just going to make this
a smaller size when people are on mobile
and then i'll just click update to save
all that
so now we got our homepage done we're
ready to go and modify the next section
of our websites so to do that i'm going
to click on preview changes and once
we're on preview changes we can now see
the different sections here well first
of all we can actually scroll down and
see what this looks like
and then we can go to the next section
which is the about page so on the about
us page i can now go to edit with
elementor
and you can see what we when you're
editing with elementor we can't see the
the heading up here and so later we're
going to talk about how to modify that
in this about page
i'm actually going to make these a
capital letters about us
and you don't even have to make this an
about us page you can make it something
else you can use the same
page in this template and modify it so
it's not an about us page but i'm going
to change this background picture here
so i'm going to go to style
choose image and i'm going to do another
search
[Music]
and this time i'm just going to use this
one here
and i'm just going to have to
okay
something to oh let's see if i click the
top button
okay that looks cool it actually lined
up pretty well if it didn't i can always
custom
the size and move this around here
but i'm going to go back to what it was
which was bottom center
and that looks pretty good
and then i'm going to
scroll down and some of these things
what we're not going to have for our
about us page
we will have this text box but i'm going
to delete this image
and instead of having this our mission
our values and this quote i'm going to
add a section with all of our team
members so i'm going to click this and
then we'll go to blocks like before if
we scroll down we can see all these
different possibilities i'm just going
to go with this one
so ins import block
and that now we can go through and make
updates so i can say
our team
and then i can even change the color of
this if i want or change the font i'm
going to go into the style and put the
color well actually click the global
colors
and
i'm going to go to uni orange and we'll
keep this the same but now we can go
through and change the images so instead
of those images
i'm going to just choose some of these
other images that were already on here
so i got that one
and now we'll have all color images
and you can see i made a mistake there
obviously so this is a good time to show
you about this history button so i can
go to history and then i can um go back
to anything so i'm going to just go back
to here
and so we went back a few steps in the
history now i'm going to
change this image to this one
and then the final image
and now you know there's already a
section that had all these different
images but i'm just showing you how you
if you want to add your own section
and i'm going to change some of the
stuff in here so i'm going to change the
style and i'm going to
change the title and we're going to use
uni orange
and what i'm going to do is just
copy this section now we can just paste
the style
paste the style and paste the style
and now i'm just going to go into
responsive mode
just to make sure everything looks good
when we're responsive
this does look pretty good i'm going to
make a change though because
i actually don't want this
there to be so much space on the top and
bottom of this text
so i'm going to click here and then we
have the minimum height right now the
minimum height is 420 but if i
change this
now there's going to be less of a space
in between the top and bottom like
around this text and then i can actually
go through and update this image
and i'm going to do custom
and i'm going to just
whoop not that position i'm going to
change this
there we go
and now this girl is still lined up
correctly
and then i'm just going to test again on
responsive mode
this is good the about it's still pretty
big on responsive mode i think how i
when i changed it it only
it it didn't only it just changed
on desktop mode so i can change on
mobile also here
and then i'm going to
update the image as well on mobile mode
okay looks good now i can click update
and then i will go to
preview changes
now this is why it's important to
preview changes you can see now this
isn't lined up exactly how i wanted it
so let me go back to edit with elementor
and i think it's because when this goes
back and forth
you can see the where the image is
placed is different well we can fix that
so i'm going to go
to style
image
and then instead of using the pixels i'm
actually going to change it to
the percentage
so if i change it to percentage
okay this is more of what i want so
it does kind of
cut off the girl a little bit the head
but really we're focused on the unicycle
so that's looking good if i go to
responsive mode
well that doesn't really make difference
okay so we'll update and then preview
changes
okay
now i'm going to go to
services
now we can go now we can on the services
page we can go through and update and
customize it but i'm going to use this
as an exa
as an opportunity to show how to remove
a section so later i'm going to remove
this whole services section from the
website so we're just gonna have the
home about and contact so let me go to
the contact page and now i'm gonna make
some updates on this contact page
so i'm gonna go to edit with elementor
okay we can see in the contact page
already there's information about where
the contact information like the email
phone number location and then there's
this form so let's see how we're going
to customize this first let's click on
this text and we're going to capitalize
it
just use title case so just like before
i'm going to change the background image
so i'll have to click this
up here to change the background of this
section here and i will go to the style
and then i'm going to choose the image
and i'm going to upload a file
and then i'm just going to insert the
media
and i'm going to change the background
overlay just like before so we can see
the contact us a little better and i'm
going to make it so
there's less space on the top and bottom
so i'm going to go to layout and change
this height here
and i'm going to adjust this position
i'm going to custom here
and let's see how we want to do this
actually we want this to be zero
and then the y position i'm going to
change the percentage
okay then we can kind of see the
unicycle there
okay now i'll just
change this i'm going to change the
color of this text
and we'll use the color we've been using
a lot i'll go to style
text
color and x whoops
i'm going to use the uni orange
and i'm going to
copy this and then i'm going to paste
the style
and then you can go through and update
the email address and the phone number
i'm just going to leave this as default
for now but
for the email um you can change you can
change if like if you want to put a dash
here or if you want to
look different here and then you can
obviously change the style by updating
the color here and then we have the
social icons down here
right now so you update them just like
we saw before where i can put the
twitter link here
and if i want to change the colors back
to like right now they're all gray but i
can
go to style and go to official color and
these will be what we would expect here
and what we really need to look at is
the form this is where it's going to be
a a little this is going to be something
new so to make it so this send message
will actually send an email we're going
to have to update this form so first let
me apply this
and update i think i just actually
needed to update so to
get this form all working correctly we
have to do that within the wordpress
dashboard instead of the elementor
dashboard so
let me go to exit to dashboard
and i can just close that out and click
here to go to the main dashboard and
then i'm going to go to wp forms here
so now we can see the forms and we just
have one form the contact form i'm going
to edit
and this is the form the styling is a
little different but this is basically
the form that's appearing on on the
website
and we can add additional things so
right now we're just asking for the name
email address message but if we want we
can add a new a new element so i'll do
go to add fields and
let's make a drop down
and then we can change it
a favorite
type of unicycle and then you can
make different choices tall
[Music]
road unicycle
or
off-road
[Music]
and then people have a drop down box
and now i'm going to go over to the
settings
and then notifications
so
this is where we're going to update
exactly what happens when someone
clicks the submit button
it's going to default be whatever email
we put as the admin email but if if you
want a different email that this email
is sent to we can type it right here
now this is the same email at
freecodecamp.org
[Music]
is the one we were using but if you're
going to update the email address here
you'll you should also update the from
email address and then if you want the
subject of the email to be different you
can change it here so this is the email
that you'll be receiving when a user of
the website sends submits the contact
form and this information is coming
directly from the contact form and then
when we're done with this we just have
to make sure to click save now it says
after saving these settings be sure to
test a form submission so you can see
how it looks so you're definitely going
to want to test this out just to make
sure everything's working but it should
all work it should all be set up to work
correctly
okay i'm going to go out of this and
we're going to go back into our
page here so if i just click here it's
going to
open this up and there's a few final
things we want to change so we've
already learned how to customize all
these pages with elementor but we want
to do a few more things we want to
update the logo here we want to i'm
going to teach you how to update this
header up here including changing this
number or possibly just removing the
phone number and then we're going to
talk about how to update this footer
here so we're not going to do that from
with elementor i'm going to go to the
customize button right here
and then i'm going to go to
header builder
and it says the header on this page is
set from the transparent header please
click the link below to customize the
transparent header so do that customize
transparent header
and we're going to decide first we're
going to decide when the header is going
to be on and it's we can just on desktop
desk on mobile or mobile and desktop
and we want to use a different logo for
the transparent parent header no we
wouldn't always use the same logo and
here is where we want to change the logo
so i'm going to update upload a new logo
and it's just this little unicycle image
so this is now going to be the the logo
it's going to appear right up top here
and then we still are going to have to
update the logo down here but we have
the new logo in our header
and
there's plenty of websites out there
that can help you make it to a logo for
your website and there's also a bunch of
tutorials on youtube on how to make a
logo or you can get a designer that to
help you make a logo for your website
but it's usually pretty important but
it's it's very helpful to have a logo
that you can use on your website that
people can start identifying your
website with your logo and then we can
go down here do we want a different logo
for written devices no we're going to
keep that off
and then the logo width i think it looks
pretty good but
we can change the logo if we wanted to
we'll let's just go back to the the
default which is 60 here
now i'm going to go back up and i do
want to actually turn this on enable on
complete website so the header will
always show up
and then you can choose if there's any
specific places where you want to
disable it so i'm just going to leave
that all as default
now let's go up here we're still
customizing the transparent header and
we're going to see what options we have
on the design so we just changed the
logo here but you can see that depending
on what your background image is you may
want some sort of color or something
behind here i think it looks pretty good
for this image but you may want a
background overlay so if i click that
see i can use some other color here i
could even try to
get like an
orange color i can change the
transparency
and i can even
choose one of these other colors here
that we have down here
and i can make it kind of transparent
now i don't really think that looks
better so i'm going to turn that off
there but there's just one option
depending on what background image you
have so i'm just going to clear that
and it seems like it's kind of frozen up
here if any if that ever happens to you
just try publishing it and then after
you publish just refresh the page or
sometimes it'll just
does it automatically so now
now it's not loading anymore but there's
a bunch of things you can change here so
we can do the the overlay we can also
change the color some of these other
things like i can change the menu color
or basically the color of these these
words here right now it's white but if
we want to change it red in this case
this is the color of our
current page we're on so see when i put
my mouse it says hover active so this is
the active page or if i'm hovering over
a page see i want to hover over it so
that's i kind of like that but i'm going
to make this an orange color here
so now when i hover over it's going to
turn orange or if we're on the page it's
going to be orange and then there's just
a bunch of other colors you can change
depending on what you're trying to do
here
so that's how you're going to change the
design and the logo but now let's see
how we can remove some of these elements
like i told you about how we're not
we're going to remove the services page
from our website so we want to remove
that so this is not where you're going
to remove this but it is where we're
going to remove this phone number here
see
if you look at this
line here we have the site logo the site
title and logo we have the primary menu
and we have a button well the button is
this thing right here so i'm just going
to click remove the button and then it's
going to remove that
okay now i'm going to try to change the
logo for this footer down here
so there's a few ways i can just start
clicking i can click this edit button
here or i can back up here
and then i'm going to go to the footer
builder
and then i will go to the design
and then i will
go to this see this html one that's the
logo here so if i click in here
we can see it's just an image
that's right in here so i'm going to
delete this image
and then i can either just leave it
deleted or i can add the logo again so
to add the logo again i'm going to do
this and then add media just click there
insert into post
and then i'm going to actually make it a
lot smaller
and then we can see that little unicycle
see once we change the size here it
changes the size here you can see that
that says copyright is the copyright
right here this thing right here we have
the footer i mean we have the footer
menu which is this menu right here and
then we have this logo here so i don't
actually
want this copy to say this i'm going to
change it so i'm going to click here and
it's going to say
made
by
bow
and it's kind of off to the side here so
let's see if i how i can change the
design a little bit
so it's not so far to the side now it's
already showing a margin of 40
but i think i'm going to actually have
to change
this this layout here
and i'm going to put some padding on the
right
okay sometimes you just have to go just
try out different things to figure out
where you have to add the padding
i had already
tried to add the padding in one other
spot i tried to add the padding here but
or the margin here but it didn't
increase anything so i just added had to
add the padding on this whole section
here
okay now i'm going to teach you how to
remove the the item from the menu
it's not on this page surprisingly
because if i click to click edit here um
oh i guess it does say configure menu
from here
but i don't think i'm going to be able
to remove an element from that menu
so no yeah so i'm not going to be able
to remove anything from the menu here so
to remove something from the menu i have
to well first of all i'm going to
publish what i have
and then i'm going to go back to the
main wordpress page the main wordpress
dashboard
now i'm going to go to appearance
and well and then menus here
okay so
we have these this menu the main menu
and you can see home about service
contact well i want to remove services
i'm going to click here and i can do the
drop down here and then
remove
and i'll just save the menu
okay let me go back to the page
now we see it says home about contact if
i scroll down to the bottom
home about contact so we've successfully
removed that page
so let's say you want to add a whole new
page to this menu so to remove a page
you just saw how to do that but to add a
page first you're going to click or
hover over the new button and then go to
page
and so you can and then after you're
adding a page i can just click edit with
elementor
and so now it's a page with nothing it
has a header it has a footer but it
doesn't have anything else i may want to
go into here go into the blocks
and
i can actually sort by different thing
i'm going to hero because usually you
want some sort of big thing at the top
and i'm going to put this and i'm going
to import this block
and then i could go through and edit the
page just like what we've been learning
i'm actually just going to put a solid
color here as the background this is
just a super quick example we're not
going to use this in the page but i'm
also going to change
this
to
just a blue up here
and then i just want to show you how you
would add this new section to the page
so it just loaded this image from just
the the template here for the this top
section here but if i click publish
and let's say i want to add this to a
link well it says hooray your page is
live have a look so this is the page
but it's not showing in the menu up here
so if i wanted to get this page in the
menu i could go to
this button here go back to the main
wordpress menu now if i look at the
pages i can see the page that was just
added
so let's see if this is the page i just
added if i click view yep this is the
page i just added so i'm going to go
back here and i'm going to do a quick
edit so i can edit the title and this is
just going to be called new
page
and the slug will just be new
page
the slug is just what's going to appear
in the url and i'll click update
and then i can add that to the menu if i
want want to by just going to appearance
menus
and
we have the new page here so i can click
add to menu and it would be here
and i could put it right before the
contact now i'm going to be deleting
this in a second but i just want to show
you how you would add a brand new page
to a menu so let me go here to visit the
site i'm on the about page and you can
see the new page
shows up right here right in the menu so
let's go and delete that new page now
i'm going to go back to the wordpress
menu i'm going to go
back to the menu so that's appearance
and menus
and then i will just
remove the new page and i can also go
whoops i forgot to
save this so save the menu
and then i will go to pages
just see all the pages and we can delete
that new page and we also can delete the
services we're not going to use that
so i'm just going to do bulk action
move to trash and i'm just going to
close these
and our page is pretty much done we're
just going to go over some final
settings so you can see it says love
nature up here that was the default name
so let's change that to what we want to
be so i'm going to go to settings here
and then we can change the name of the
the title and the tagline this is
important because it is going to appear
in some places so you want to make sure
it's accurate so for the site title
we'll just put in
the unicycle
store
the place to buy unicycles
and by the way
i did not set this up as an online store
but i do have another tutorial about how
to create a wordpress online store so
you can check that out if you want and
i'll put the link to that in the
description and then let's just go down
here and then see if there's any other
settings we want to update
so
you can you can change the date format
that's going to appear or the time
format now this is mainly going to
appear if you were doing a blog post in
this tutorial we did not cover how to
make blog posts
but uh if if you want you can update
these formats you can change when the
week starts on i'm going to say it
starts on a sunday and then i'm going to
go to save changes
okay our page is basically done and we
have learned the basics of elementor you
can see as i was demonstrating things
there's just a bunch more menu so this
was kind of learning the basics and you
should now know enough to start figuring
out more things on your own you just
explore the menus and
remember when you're doing things in the
menus you can always do the undo you can
always go back in the history so you
don't have to worry about messing
anything up you now know the basics of
using elementor to create and customize
your website thanks for watching and
good luck on creating your own website